[Music]
dr. King's legacy is very very strong
today you know he was one of non-violent
and a very very important person in the
Civil Rights Act during that time and
his legacy is always about it was always
about love and that's what I try to do
through my music around the world just
bring love and unity through harmony
through everyone and without dr. King
I'm not sure where we will be today very
important figure in American history dr.
King what he meant to me growing up as a
man was that he was very brave to be
able to take on such a big big task to
move the nation forward with everybody
with equality and everybody treated
being treated equally and through our
love so to me he just was a man of pride
and and he wanted to do the right thing
and he died for that so everyone can be
treated with love and respect and equal
and that's how I want to live my life
treat everyone with love and treat
everyone with equality and make sure
that everything is just good as people
my first memory of Martin Luther King I
think I was in elementary school and
they made us watch I have a dream speech
and seeing that in black and white and
seeing all those people together it was
just a very very powerful moment even at
a young age if I didn't understand how
powerful he was and what his
significance was to us at that moment I
felt the spirit hit me and and as I got
older I started to really understand
what he meant to us without dr. King
doing what he did and believing in what
he did things would probably be much
different so we needed leaders like him
during that particular time to fight for
the rights of the people so we can all
be treated and legalized ratio
segregation you know so we have Louis
Armstrong who played in front of
segregated crowds because he come up
playing in 9th early 1900s and through
people like him and dr. King I think I
am able what we were able to do what we
do
today and be around the world and play
for different audiences of all colors
and because he took that stand to do the
right thing I'm here today because of
that dr. King inspired my music because
my music has no color barriers you know
it's just love I don't go out preaching
about love and not just play my horn and
the sounds of New Orleans bring people
together around the world and through
music that's what I'm that's what's
happening naturally without saying but
that's what he that was his whole
message let's get together in harmony
and love one love and that's what music
brings to people so it's a big influence
on me because I just make music I don't
I don't say who listened to it I don't
see who liked it and when you come to my
shows it's very diverse you can see
Asians black Mexicans whatever it may be
and it's a beautiful thing to be onstage
to be able to watch that happening
everybody getting along even if it's
full of hour and 30 minutes you can see
what dr. King was trying to do
throughout the world I think just
playing music making noise bringing
rhythms together that that says it all
you know it's a universal language and
people just when you hear that beat it
doesn't matter who you are where you're
from you're gonna come in dance and
that's I think and directly through
music that's what happens so I never
know some titles anything because I
don't I'm not really a political person
on my show when I come when you come to
my show it's just fun stories about
maybe being in the club dancing or being
in the French quarters or Bourbon Street
or whatever it may be it's just really a
happy time and I don't bring the
politics into to my music because
everyone should be there to enjoy
themselves through music you know take
them away from whatever atmosphere they
may be in or whatever is going on in
their life they can come here and let
that all go I don't think there's not
one day that I don't think about music
or create music even flying back on long
flights from overseas I've got my
computer I'm making beats of tracks or
whatever it may be and I do find it very
therapeutic and people around the world
I see people dancing even here in New
Orleans you'll see people dancing down
the street with no music their feet
making the music they got on type of
rhythm and the way they danced and it
just the way people talk to you they'll
say your name what a melody so it's a
very very important aspect of life and a
component that we need I think music is
so powerful because it's it's something
we can feel and we can't see it and when
you can feel something that's the spirit
speaking to where we all in one you know
so when music brings people together and
we can dance and I don't know what the
world would be without music it's very
very important you know all types of
music if that's a punk-rocker if it's a
country whatever it may be you can
always find some type of thing to hold
on to and styles of music that people
love
some of it is unexplainable you have to
be there his legacy resonated for five
decades because it's still very relevant
today
you know things that's happening today I
was sitting down with my grandmother and
we were watching TV and some of the
things that's happening in the world she
said it's not as bad as it used to be
but it's the same thing and for she's 80
something years old so for that for me
to hear her say that she can always go
back to dr. King and his message of what
he was trying to do and she was able to
live through that and see some of the
progress but still it's still the same
type of thing that's happening so for me
to sit there and see her say that and
what she went through for us to be able
to be today it's a hard thing but his
message until we able to get together in
unity in love his message will always be
the same it will always be relevant and
always be to progress as human beings
and come come together so his message is
always there with that message is
timeless and that's what we need and we
needed him to be that that the point the
vocal point for us to make that happen
so and until things change
it gets better his message will always
be the same I'm not sure what dr. King
would think of today because some of the
things are still happening it's just
like repeating
history and I'm not sure if he would be
if he would feel let down that whatever
he did that he tried to do but he this
is what he fought for but I think
there's some small progressions that's
happening but is it still that net still
not there but if he was here today I
think he would still have the same
message until until he wasn't able to
say it again I'm very very blessed that
dr. King was brave enough to move
forward and take that on and lose his
life and sacrifice for the right thing
because we do have some progressions and
and we're very thankful for him and the
people during that time to stand up for
that and give us a better platform to
base ourselves off as people if I could
say something to dr. King first of all I
was thinking for being as brave as he
was to take on that leadership during
the civil rights movement and and and
the way that he did it with non-violence
I would just be all praise to him to
thank him for understanding that someone
needed to take that task to be able to
move things things forward and I would
tell them that I understood that he knew
that he was fighting a long fight for me
today and for other people in every
American and people around the world I
would tell them that I understood that
and I really appreciate him taking that
stands to make things better in the
world and do the right thing under one
love when I watch videos of dr. King
speaking it's almost as if you're at a
concert you know sometimes you can watch
James Brown and he can sing a certain
note and somebody will pass out or
they'll feel the certain word and dr.
King was the same way through his
ministry and he had a way of exciting
the crowd and being emotional enough to
where it was genuine so they can feel it
and when something is that genuine
no matter what you're doing if you
speaking are playing music it'll have
that effect on you
I'm directing influence of the city of
New Orleans and everything we do is
about feeling in music so I'm just
carrying that on through music without
without speaking about it
but it's it's basically the same thing
the spirit and the music and when that
whole thing just takes over your body
and you can't run from it no matter who
you are you can't run from that feeling
I hope that I can influence the next
generation of future generations through
love and music and just let them know
that we're all one and music brings
unity and then we can act in harmony
around the world and be a much better
place and always do things out of
kindness of your heart and through love
and through with that I think we'll be
okay if we can just keep that passing
along through a generation generation
that thing
my great-great-great grandchildren will
be able to have a better situation and
feel the love a little bit easier than
we do
[Music]